the movie is set in the year 2061 the
Sun is going through a rapidly
deteriorating phase and will soon turn
into a red giant this threatens to
engulf the Earth's orbit within 100
years and consequently destroy the blue
planet in order to survive the
destruction of Earth Human Society has
gone through a drastic change putting
their differences aside all the
countries of the globe have been merged
to form the United Earth government or
the ueg since then the ueg has initiated
a daring project known as the wandering
Earth Project the plan is to drive the
Earth to its new home the Alpha Centauri
which is a gravitationally bound system
of stars and planets much like the solar
system it is 4.37 light years from the
Sun the Earth is predicted to take
around 20 years to complete her journey
to this new solar system moreover the
project has deployed 12 000 enormous
fusion-powered Earth engines built
across the Northern Hemisphere it has
also employed torque engines along the
Equator to slowly Propel the entirety of
planet Earth out of the original orbit
okay still following oh you are damn
you're smarter than I am at the start of
the movie a Chinese astronaut named Liu
Peking oversees the gravitational
slingshot maneuver of Earth which uses
the gravity of Jupiter to assist
propulsion after completing his job
Peking leaves for his next mission to
the navigation platform an International
Space Station leaving his young son
liuki and foster daughter Han duo duo
aboard the navigation Lee's job is to
help navigate the Earth along its
Interstellar Journey several years
passed by and much of the human
population has died out due to the
multiple violent natural disasters this
includes gigantic tsunamis that occur
after Earth's rotation is brought to a
halt moreover as the planet distances
from the Sun most of the surface becomes
frozen solid as a result the remaining
humans are forced to live in vast
underground cities built adjacent to and
under the several Earth engines 17 years
later it is the Chinese New Year of
2078. and Peking and his colleagues are
set to return to Earth after finishing
their work at the International Space
Station elsewhere Peking's son liuki has
now grown into an adult he works as a
machinist of heavy trucks most remaining
humans who now live underground rarely
get a chance to see life on the surface
of the Earth including liuki he's always
wanted to go on a ride on the Earth's
surface but it's nearly impossible due
to the catastrophic climate however one
day he decides to fulfill his dream one
way or another he illegally obtains two
thermal suits and fake IDs liuki
smuggles some special instant inflatable
bubble capsules to a couple of local
thugs in exchange for the goods so he
can see life on the surface himself he
also brings his little sister hondu oduo
along for helping him steal a truck's
key and clearance pass of their grandpa
Han Jiang it turns out Xiang works as a
driver for the wandering Earth Project
later when liuki and his sister reach
the surface they are awed by the huge
structure called Earth engine which is
only one of the two twelve thousand
scattered across the Earth they then
illegally requisitioned Han jiang's
heavy transport vehicle and drive around
at first Liu Ki being a novice driver
drives very clumsily and almost causes
an accident but soon he gets the hang of
it and drives with confidence however
the brother sister Duo are soon stopped
at a nearby checkpoint and thrown into
jail their grandpa Han Jiang learns
about the development and arrives to
rescue them he tries to bribe the jail
Warden to free his grandchildren but
ends up getting thrown into the same
cell as them meanwhile on board the
space station Peking is getting ready to
return to Earth it is his final shift
and it's exactly the same day the Earth
is supposed to Glide past Jupiter and
accelerate to achieve the necessary
speed of flying out of the solar system
however things don't go as planned and
as Earth approaches Jupiter to make use
of a gravity assist unexpectedly
Jupiter's gravity becomes irregular the
spike in Tidal force causes devastating
earthquakes on Earth which disables many
Earth engines across the globe as a
result of this the underground cities
are are crushed While others are drowned
by lava killing hundreds in the process
to make matters worse Jupiter starts
exerting tremendous levels of
gravitational force on Earth this means
that the two planets will collide very
soon amidst the chaos liuki his sister
and hanjiang managed to escape the
prison with a fellow inmate named Tim
Tim's name is by far the easiest to say
so far after getting out Jiang finds his
heavy track takes his grandchildren and
Tim in and starts driving like a pro he
avoids large buildings rocks and other
structures on the way Zhang's plan is to
take everyone to another underground
city elsewhere as the navigation
platform is on its way to Earth its main
computer AI the Moss warns everyone that
the space station will soon go into low
energy mode hence all of them should go
into hibernation however Peking who is
adamant on meeting his family requests
for some time and calls his father Han
Jiang on the call he learns about their
imprisonment and the subsequent
earthquakes he also finds out that his
family is in a truck so he directs them
to the nearest anchor after that he goes
to his quarters and prepares to
hibernate on the other hand hanjiang's
truck is intercepted by a rescue team of
elite Chinese soldiers who are on an
emergency Mission led by Captain Wang
lay they demand the truck to transport a
precious cargo called lighter core which
can allegedly be used to ignite the
Earth engines they want to use the
lighter core to restart the o1 Earth
engine in Hangzhou as expected Han Jiang
is not happy about the order but he is
forced to oblige soon pakiang learns
about the new development and requests
Swang lay let his family go into a
bunker however the latter replies that
he can only let them go after hanjiang
helps them complete their mission left
with no choice hanjiang drives them to
Shanghai where a huge Tremor has torn
open a long Gap showing the old city
covered by Ice as the truck goes into
the Gap hanjiang tells stories about his
memories in the city a flashback shows
thousands of people frozen solid in the
ice and it's revealed that liuki's
sister was among the few survivors and
she was adopted by Han Jiang as the old
man continues narrating the story
suddenly a second Tremor hit and cliffs
on both sides of the Gap start
collapsing everyone abandons their
vehicles and rushes to the tallest
building of Shanghai sadly the
devastation has only just begun for the
group as they climbed through the
building everything starts moving
violently they try getting to a safe
location with the lighter core but
things do not go as planned because of
the heavy Tremors the team loses a
soldier whereas Han Jiang is isolated on
a separate floor when the old man
realizes that his oxygen is running out
he opens his helmet and freezes himself
to death in the next scene liuki
confronts Wang lay and blames him for
his grandfather's death in a fit of rage
he also attacks the captain but gets
easily overpowered after the scuffle
liuki declares that he will no longer be
a part of the mission left with no
choice the elite team carries the
lighter core themselves and marches
towards the Earth engine in Hangzhou
while liuki his sister and Tim start
heading back home I loved him elsewhere
aboard the space station just after the
hibernation program begins Peking learns
from Moss that his family is missing and
that the Earth has plunged into a new
round of chaos the AI also asserts that
the Earth is beyond saving so they are
not heading there anymore now Moss has
prioritized a new Mission rather than
assisting Earth the station is planning
to serve as an Interstellar Arc to seed
a new planet with Earth's biosphere they
plan to send a selected bunch of people
along with some crops and other things
to the new planet so that Earth's Legacy
can live on forever hearing this Peking
becomes enraged and refuses to give up
on Earth he then tries to break out of
the forced hibernation but just then
Moss wakes up the other members of the
team to rectify the situation but
surprisingly a Russian teammate markarov
decides to help Peking the two of them
blow open a hatch closest and fly out
into the vacuum to reach the control
center markarov sacrifices himself and
pushes Peking towards a moving arm
fortunately the plan works and Peking
gets hold of the control center back on
Earth liuki and his companions find a
crashed plane with a truck intact inside
they meet the sole survivor Lee yi yi
who is a crazy genius
reveals to them I can't say this name ye
reveals to them that Jupiter's gravity
is sucking Earth's atmosphere to such a
degree that the air is too thin even to
fly a plane he also tells the group that
there may still be hope for people on
Earth but for that they need to rescue a
gigantic torque engine in sulawesi at
the equator hearing this liuki gets
riled up but at first he decides to save
the Earth engine in Hangzhou in the
space station pikiang gets into the
computer room and tries to override Moss
but the AI informs him that it is merely
carrying out orders authorized by the
United Earth government meanwhile
outside of Hangzhou the elite team finds
out that the whole city is lost to the
lava the Earth engine there is damaged
Beyond repair soon another man dies in
The Mission and with this the team
starts contemplating on whether to
continue the mission or not in
frustration a female Soldier shoots at
the lighter core and breaks it prompting
the captain to almost kill her for it
just then liuki and his group show up in
the truck and liuki tells the elite team
about the torque engine at sulawesi this
intrigues Wang lay and he agrees to help
liuki and his group in their mission to
sulawesi when they almost reach sulawesi
they learn that some other teams had
successfully repaired the engines before
them however the combined thrust of the
engines is no longer able to divert the
trajectory with Earth approaching
Jupiter's Roche limit in the space
station after Moss explains to Peking
that all rescue missions are useless it
opens a channel to Earth and broadcasts
to everyone that they have only seven
days until the Earth gets torn apart
hearing the bad news liuki becomes
devastated and reveals that they
actually have only one day to live
because Jupiter is sucking their Air at
a tremendous rate later as a heartbroken
liuki is staring at the massive Planet
an idea suddenly strikes his mind since
Jupiter is composed of 90 percent
hydrogen and it has been sucking a lot
of oxygen from Earth lately a tiny spark
can ignite the entire planet with the
impact from the ignition Earth can be
blown away to a safe distance liuki
immediately shares his plan with the
genius yi yi and surprisingly the latter
likes it soon they hack the sulawesi
engine and concentrate its power to fire
a plasma beam tall enough to ignite
Jupiter the group overcomes various
challenges and are able to reconfigure
the engine to carry out the plan but are
unable to push the firing pin of the
engine to ignite it left with no options
the captain Wang lay calls the nearby
rescue workers to help huh I thought he
was going to sacrifice himself but
everyone ignores him that's deserved
just then liuki's sister hondu o Duo
realizes that she can make an emergency
call to the space station and ask for
her father's help she contacts Peking
and briefs him about the plan but Moss
reveals that some Israeli scientists
already had this idea and the chance of
success is zero nevertheless Peking
still calls the ueg and pleads for
authorization Nation the ueg refuses to
send in backup but let's duo duo
broadcast her message to the remaining
Rescuers with this opportunity the
little girl delivers an emotional speech
which warms the hearts of people all
across the world probably not as much as
that lava did though and in no time
several Rescuers arrive at the scene and
start helping the group to push the
giant pin in the next scene liuki
finally gets the machine unstuck now
everything is ready except the launch
program the main technician yi yi is
badly injured by Falling Rocks but he
somehow manages to put the right Cable
in the socket at last the program
finally gets uploaded the torque engine
shoots a straight red light toward the
Giant Eye Of Jupiter but the power
cannot reach the ignition area it is
short by a mere 5000 kilometers Peking
who is also witnessing all of this
suddenly remembers that his space
station has thirty thousand tons of fuel
which should generate 5 000 kilometers
of flame if ignited he explains the plan
to Moss but the AI declines and instead
locks the system Moss is a dick bag
enraged Peking burns the main computer
and takes charge of the space station he
then steers toward Jupiter at a high
speed and collides in no time Jupiter's
atmosphere starts burning and Earth is
pushed away by the impact but sadly the
impact also releases giant impact waves
which start ravaging Earth amidst the
chaos liuki finds his sister with Tim
just then the impact wave hits and sends
everyone flying no not Tim Tim holds on
to a pipe but liuki sees his sister
dropping down so he falls towards her in
the air he heroically catches her and
deploys an instant bubble capsule which
saves both of their lives however the
fall breaks leaves helmet and he slowly
passes out before he closes his eyes he
sees that the Earth survived the ordeal
the movie then fast forwards to three
years in the future where liuki has
become a driver and has earned
everyone's respect well I would goddamn
hope so moreover the engines have
resumed working and humanity is heading
in the right direction to restore its
past Glory hell yeah Yeah Tim survived
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching